we haven't seen a whole lot of footage
from the season it we have anything
other glimpses of your work room
entrances really yeah
did you make it this Vangie miss fan
g-men
Vangie
[ __ ] I'm back how would you describe
your work room entrance sickening
sickening sickening everything I know I
look good thank y'all
appreciate you cut the check later [ __ ]
I ever said if I was gonna get on drag
race there was one specific look I
wanted to do and I did it and I'm so
excited for everybody to see like the
full thing you're a Disney fan you're
gonna love it so I'm super excited now
this is what dreams are made of yes give
you a little Hilary Duff realness move
over ladies this race just took an odd
turn I'd say it's very like Disney
villain like we've got another girl in
the cast Nina who's totally like the
Disney like fairy godmother and I'm
totally that evil [ __ ] I'm like beating
everybody apples so I'm sabotaging
welcome to season 11 it looks like
things just got 11 June daring
over-the-top it's larger than life and
it's so classic and to me that's what
drag is much much crunch crunch silky
ganache is here to eat the love
oh just a the fat girl from around the
block coming in to the BBQ ready to eat
ready to sit on a few holes and that was
my mouth I was dressed as a Mountie one
of the Royal Canadian Mounted Police so
I kind of want to do like a high-fashion
version of that soap a little shout out
to Canada
[Music]
never fear the queen of the north is
here she our national to be here in
compete as a Canadian as the first
Canadian and represent my country is
everything the Government of Canada
tweeted about me whoa did you know that
read all about it
Roger O'Hara's in the house and I hope
you came to play cuz you know Roger is
all about the tea she's spreading the
tea and you gotta get your news page
news baby
this honey raw and unfiltered my work
with insurance was inspired by Thierry
Mugler insect collection it was a beef I
don't want to be on drag race for most
of my career which is ten years now and
I've submitted eight audition tapes so I
knew when I walked in a workroom exactly
what I wanted to wear like six years ago
I was like this is what I will wear on
that day and I'll come in and boom and
then I got to okay my work the room
entrance is all about my family the
house of diamonds as you can see it is
all of our jewelry you can get it
represent your name so it's all about
the grand
the last time you come in a fight it's
fully my tech window uniform that I
turned it into my dress and I'm actually
wearing my own actual fifth degree black
belt so you can like see the stripes and
stuff because I didn't want that girls
to like you know like watch out better
bring a large look yeah yes yes so like
don't you mean I look cute but don't
she's penis with the peanuts honey
oh the world wants me and the feeling is
mutual
she's cinched and she's naked and so my
whole look is based on that that
portrait of Venus going back to I think
she's going back to this see I came in
expecting the unexpected turns out that
I'm going up plastic tear out cool
Vietnam I could be throwing the fire I
could be throwing the volcano I could be
diving across the ocean so I wanted
something still elegant still Mia still
beautiful but I can still move and run
away from the crocodiles if I need to
like fashion but can run quick exactly
exactly
legs free yeah my workroom interest is
giving very Housewives of Atlanta or as
I should say Housewives of RuPaul's Drag
Race
oh yes it's me mr. Curia da BTN PR and
as you can see I'm the [ __ ] I
just want to come in and be relaxed but
also give you a little body a little sex
kitten you know give you a very
housewives clubbing ability Vegas is
back in that house and this time we
should exactly my workroom entrance was
inspired like hip-hop you know ballerina
sir girl you know I just like to throw
little inspirations all in one I'm from
Vegas I'm a dancer so that's where I got
my inspiration it was crazy
get ready off cuz this sugar is so sweet
I was wearing a beautiful outfit that
was representative of New York City the
blonde and it was surreal I remember
just like walking in and thinking wait
it's actually smaller than I thought but
it was just it was a crazy was just like
a dream come true my queen welcome to
RuPaul's Drag Race
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]